yesterday of course the limit on
attendances at outdoor public events was
lifted
the remaining statutory measures
introduced in response to omicron are as
follows limits on attendance at indoor
public events the requirement for one
metre physical distancing between
different groups in indoor public places
the requirement for table service and
hospitality premises serving alcohol on
the premises and the closure of
nightclubs
given the improving situation and as i
said last week we hoped to be able to do
i can confirm today that all of these
measures will be lifted from next monday
24th january
we will also from monday remove the
guidance advising adults against
non-professional indoor contact sports
so that these can resume as normal and
from monday we will also lift the
guidance asking people to stick to a
three household limit on indoor
gatherings however it is important i
think to stress this point
notwithstanding the improving situation
the level of covered infection
circulating in the community is still
high
so to minimize the risk of getting the
virus it would be sensible for all of us
to remain cautious in our social
interactions at this stage even though
from monday we will no longer recommend
a fixed upper limit on numbers of
households if we all continue to keep
gatherings as small as our circumstances
allow for now i would suggest until the
end of this month we will reduce our
chances of getting infected and of
course we should continue to take
lateral flow tests before meeting up
with people from other households please
also remember to record test results
whether positive or negative through the
uk government website at let me stress
this is even more important now that we
are no longer advising confirmatory pcr
tests for those without symptoms who
test positive through lateral flow
devices recording these results ensures
that we are able to make better
assessments of the trends in infection
finally presenting officer we will
continue to ask people to work from home
whenever possible at this stage and for
employers to facilitate this however we
will engage with business now about a
return to a more hybrid approach from
the start of february
the baseline mitigation measures that
were in place before omicron and the
requirement for businesses service
providers and places of worship to take
reasonable measures to minimise the
spread of covered on their premises will
be retained at this stage to help keep
covert contained as this wave recedes
that means face coverings it should
still be worn must still be worn in
public indoor settings and on public
transport businesses and other
organizations should continue to have
regard to guidance and take reasonable
steps to minimize the spread of covert
and hospitality premises should continue
to collect contact details for customers
which is of course important for the
effective operation of test and protect
in addition the covert certification
scheme will continue to apply for now to
large indoor and outdoor events and to
late night venues all settings where
transmission risks can be higher
as of yesterday guidance stipulates the
organisers of events with a thousand or
more in attendance should check the
certification status of at least 50 of
attendees or a thousand people whichever
is higher
now i indicated last week the cabinet
would consider and decide today whether
or not to extend the certification
scheme to other premises such as
licensed hospitality venues
this was undoubtedly the most difficult
decision we faced this morning and yet
again the judgment we have arrived at
was finally balanced on the one hand
extending covert certification could
offer public health benefits ensuring
that people attending certain venues are
vaccinated or tested it reduces to some
extent the risks of transmission and
also the risk of serious illness should
an individual contract a virus in one of
these settings on the other hand we
understand that extending certification
could create additional costs for
businesses at an already very
challenging time and of course the
smaller the business the more difficult
these costs can be to bear so the task
for cabinet today was to weigh these
considerations and decide what in the
current circumstances would be
proportionate
given that cases are now falling quite
rapidly and the current wave is receding
we decided that we will not at this
stage extend the covert certification
scheme to other premises we will of
course reconsider this should
circumstances and therefore the balance
of judgment change in any significant
way
if cases were to start to rise very
sharply again extension of certification
may well be a more proportionate
alternative to other more restrictive
measures however our conclusion today
given the improving situation is that
extending certification would not be
proportionate at this stage there is
though one reasonably minor change to
the certification regulations that we
will propose at the moment nightclubs
and other late night venues must apply
the scheme if they have in use a
designated area for dancing we intend to
amend the definition here to provide
greater clarity and prevent premises
from avoiding certification simply by
having tables on a dance floor and
therefore claiming it's not a dance
floor but nevertheless permitting
dancing to take place this change will
take effect from monday when late night
venues are able to reopen
finally presiding officer let me say a
few words about the updated rules on
self-isolation after a positive covet
test these rules confirmed two weeks ago
remain in place
if you test positive you will be advised
to self-isolate for 10 days however if
you don't have a fever and you take two
negative lateral flow tests more than 24
hours apart on day six and day seven you
can end self isolation on day seven last
week the uk government announced further
changes to self-isolation for england
this was publicised as allowing people
to end self-isolation after day five
essentially however this change simply
brings england rules into line with
those already in force in scotland this
is because in scotland we count the day
of a positive test as day one of
isolation in england this is counted as
day zero in addition in england you can
end self-isolation after day five in
scotland you can end it on day seven so
the slightly different ways of defining
the beginning and the end of the
self-isolation period has given the
impression of difference but the
substance the period that people are
actually required to self-isolate for is
in fact the same in scotland and in
england and i think it's important that
people are clear
about that deciding officer the lifting
from monday of the protections
introduced in response to omicron is
possible in part because of the efforts
everyone has made voluntarily and as a
result of guidance and statutory
measures to help stem transmission and i
want to put on record again today my
thanks to people across the country